Avengers: Endgame delivers an epic conclusion
for the MCU's founding fathers, Tony Stark
and Steve Rogers.
And that spectacular ending is one that Marvel
carefully constructed, laying an intricate
trail of clues over the past 22 movies.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and today
I'm excited to reveal all the foreshadowing
and hidden symbolism in the MCU that cleverly
predicted Iron Man's ultimate destiny.
Plus, I'll be breaking down every amazing
detail you might have missed in the Endgame
finale and explaining what it means for the
future of the MCU.
To celebrate the film's release, I'm kicking
off a special Marvel giveaway.
Subscribe and leave a comment about the movie
for a chance to win.
Obviously, we're in the Endgame now for spoilers,
so take care if you haven't seen the movie
yet.
As Tony himself says in this movie, 'part
of the journey is the end.'
And in the final big battle, after it seemed
like the Mad Titan would win yet again, Tony
made the ultimate sacrifice, stealing back
the Infinity Stones from Thanos and snapping
them in his own gauntlet.
This dusted Thanos and his army, but also
mortally wounded Tony as the radiation from
the snap burned up his armour and body.
Tony's final words to the world before he
snapped were "I am Iron Man", a perfect retort
to Thanos's line 'I am inevitable' which the
Mad Titan uttered just before trying and failing
to snap for the last time.
But more than that, Tony's final words are
also a perfect call-back to the end of the
first Iron Man movie which launched the MCU.
"I'm just not the hero type.
Clearly.
With this laundry list of character defects,
all the mistakes I've made.
The truth is.
I am Iron Man."
After what happened in Endgame, it's interesting
to look back to the Avengers early days together,
when Steve told Tony:
"The only thing you really fight for is yourself.
You're not the guy to make the sacrifice play,
to lay down on a wire and let the other guy
crawl over you.
I think I would just cut the wire."
Yet Tony proved he was willing to sacrifice
himself for the greater good during the Battle
of New York and most recently in Endgame,
and even back when he faced off with Obadiah
Stane.
But his ultimate sacrifice was most poignantly
foreshadowed in Age of Ultron when Tony talked
to Nick Fury about the terrible vision he'd
seen of his legacy.
Scarlet Witch induced the vision in Tony,
but it was a product of his own fears about
the future and, as he explained to Fury, what
he dreaded most wasn't dying, but that he'd
watch the others die while he survived.
"And I'm the man who killed the Avengers.
I saw them all dead, Nick.
I felt it.
The whole world, too.
I was shown.
Wasn't a nightmare, it was my legacy.
The end of the path I started us on."
Some parts of Tony's vision such as the invading
Leviathans and Cap's broken shield did come
true during the final battle in Endgame.
However, unlike Infinity War where Tony had
to watch many of his fellow heroes turn to
dust, this time he saved the Avengers and
died instead, creating the legacy he wanted.
Indeed, it's been clear since the very first
Iron Man movie just how crucial the notion
of legacy was to Tony, as even in those days
the idea of leaving behind a legacy of death
was something that weighed heavy on his mind:
"We're a weapons manufacturer.
"Obie, I just don't want a body count to be
our only legacy."
Back then, Tony tried rewriting his legacy
by ending his company's manufacture of weapons;
but that turned out to be small potatoes compared
to what he had to do to change his legacy
today.
"We can bust arms dealers all the livelong
day, but that up there, that's...
That's the endgame."
Doctor Strange knew that Iron Man was the
key to defeating Thanos.
In Infinity War, Strange checked over 14 million
scenarios and found only one where the Avengers
triumphed over the Mad Titan.
"I went forward in time to view alternate
futures.
To see all the possible outcomes of the coming
conflict.
How many did you see?
14,000,605.
How many did we win?
One."
Once Doctor Strange knew this, he did a complete
180 on his previous threat that he'd sacrifice
Iron Man's life to save the Time Stone, and
instead he willingly gave the stone to Thanos
in order to stop him from killing Tony.
"Stop.
Spare his life...
and I will give you the stone."
The Sorcerer Supreme knew Iron Man had to
survive through Infinity War and actually
told Tony there was "no other way" just before
he faded to dust.
Then in Endgame, when Thanos was on the verge
of victory yet again after defeating each
of the heroes one-by-one, Doctor Strange reminded
Tony that he was the only person who could
win the battle for them.
He did this by turning to Tony and holding
up a single finger, a reminder that Tony's
sacrifice was the one and only way to beat
Thanos.
Looking back to Civil War then, when Hawkeye
called Tony 'the futurist' who 'sees all'
and 'knows what's best for you', whether you
like it or not, although that was an easter
egg to both the comics and Robert Downey Junior's
music album, and although Hawkeye was annoyed
and mocking Tony when he said it, it turns
out that Hawkeye's words were pretty accurate.
Thanks to Doctor Strange, Tony was the only
living Avenger who realised there was just
a single way to win the war they were waging
once and for all.
As Thanos said in Infinity War, Tony was indeed
cursed with knowledge
Tony's death is, of course, heart-breaking
as his friends and fellow Avengers Rhodey
and Peter Parker find him dying and Pepper
comes over and tells him he "can rest now".
Even in Endgame, when Tony tried to stay away
from the Avengers and live a peaceful life
with his daughter Morgan and Pepper, he couldn't
do it.
When he solved the time travel conundrum that
the Avengers were facing, he felt he should
lock the discovery away and destroy it so
he couldn't go off on another adventure.
But the pull of the Iron Man suit and his
desire to be the hero and tech genius has
always been too strong, from revealing himself
as Iron Man at the press conference in his
first film to taking on his last, incredibly
dangerous mission in Endgame.
For Tony, living and dying as Iron Man was
basically his destiny.
And what an amazing 11-year journey it's been
for his character and what a long way he's
come from being a man reluctant to act against
terrorists using his company's weapons.
"Are you going to do something about it?
Why should I do anything?
They're going to kill me, you, either way.
And if they don't, I'll probably be dead in
a week."
To becoming a man prepared to offer himself
up for the good of others.
Tony's final stand against Thanos was 'the
last act of defiance of the great Tony Stark',
to quote Yinsen who urged Tony not to waste
his life just before he died saving the billionaire
genius in Afghanistan.
And Tony certainly took those words on board.
Ultimately, then, what Tony told Pepper back
in 2008 about his evolution turned out to
be true:
"If I were Iron Man, I'd have this girlfriend
who knew my true identity.
She'd be a wreck, 'cause she'd always be worrying
that I was going to die, yet so proud of the
man I'd become.
She'd be wildly conflicted."
Fortunately, as we see during Tony's voiceover
in Endgame, after his death his legacy has
been to restore the heroes and people who
were snapped away, so he's brought a happy
ending to many in the universe.
And, for us in the audience, we can also feel
Tony's legacy during the memorial that Pepper
holds for him.
After she releases a wreath of flowers with
the "Proof that Tony Stark has a heart" arc
reactor, the camera slowly pans over so many
of the wonderful characters we've been introduced
to in the MCU, from the very first film through
to the penultimate movie, then finally on
to Nick Fury, the man who laid the groundwork
to bring them all together in the MCU's very
first post-credits scene in the Iron Man movie.
What this scene really represents then is
the legacy of marvellous superheroes that
Iron Man has given to us, the fans.
By the way, there's a lovely little cameo
in this funeral scene by Harley Keener, the
young boy who Tony met in Iron Man 3.
It's the same actor, Ty Simpkins, and he's
standing behind Wanda, Bucky and Sam.
Although these scenes have brought many to
tears, there's still another part to Tony's
legacy which is that his daughter Morgan looks
like she's inherited his desire to put on
the Iron Man suit.
She not only picks up an Iron Man helmet from
Tony's garage at the beginning of the movie,
but just like her father, when Happy asks
Morgan what she'd like to eat, she asks for
a cheeseburger, which is exactly what Tony
demanded after he was brought back from Afghanistan.
"There are two things I want to do.
I want an American cheeseburger, and the other...
That's enough of that.
Hogan, drive.
Cheeseburger first."
In Tony's BARF message, he also says that
Morgan will face the same forces of darkness
and light that he battled during his life
and, in a tender moment, he echoes his daughter's
words to him from earlier in the movie, "I
love you 3000."
But there's one last tribute to the great
Tony Stark which you might just have missed
unless you stayed right until the very end
of the credits.
Rather than an actual post-credits scene,
we just hear the sound of metal clanking over
the Marvel Studios logo.
It's a call-back to the first Iron Man movie
when Tony had to forge his own Iron Man suit
while he was being held prisoner.
And, of course, that cave scene was also referenced
at the beginning of Endgame when Tony and
Nebula worked together to fix the ship's broken
fuel cells in a similar way to how Tony and
Yinsen collaborated to make the suit in Iron
Man.
For me, Endgame's little post-credits teaser
symbolises not only that Iron Man was the
cornerstone of the MCU, his birth and death
bookending this chapter in the franchise's
history, but also how Tony's spirit and determination
lives on [in the Marvelverse], and how the
work he started still continues, with Marvel
busily putting together a new era of movies,
TV shows, and stories for fans to enjoy.
Steve Rogers also got a big send-off in Endgame
and I've broken down everything you need to
know about the evolution of Captain America
in the MCU plus what Steve's ending with Peggy
Carter really means in my next video.
You can tap up right for the link to that
video or check the video description for the
link as soon as it's ready.
Now, what do you think about Tony's ending
in Endgame?
Comment below and subscribe to enter my Marvel
giveaway!
Tap left for that Captain America video, or
tap right for my full Marvel playlist.
And if you enjoy deep-dives like this about
your favourite movies, hit the bell to get
all my new videos.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!